Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Sag mal, wir hatten noch gesagt, dass du mir nicht mehr daher schnüffeln sollst. Dachte, wir hatten da ein Abkommen.
Also ich mache das ja nicht wissentlich. Ähm das passiert.
Aus Versehen, aber jetzt nicht absichtlich oder so.
Logbuchnetzpolitik. Nummer einhundertundvierzig und jetzt wieder hier in äh.
Das ist schön, das freut mich, Tim. Und ich möchte auch an dieser Stelle lobend erwähnen, wie früh du aufgestanden bist, um damit deine Republika geprägte Stimme ein bisschen auf den frühen Morgen zu schieben.
Ja, ich kann ja hier meine Schlafzimmerstimme nicht allen vorenthalten, das muss ja auch irgendwie sein.
Oder damit werde ich dir das das Podcast.
Der bist doch eh schon.
Ja, gibt's auch noch so ein paar andere Kandidaten. Da wird schon ganz ganz gut so die Google gerollt, teilweise. Ja.
Echt wohl, wo der noch, wer wäre jetzt am Beispiel?
Die Hörsuppe zum Beispiel.
Ja
Also ja ist schon schon ganz schön. Aber jetzt aber so nach so einer Woche Durchzeichenkonferenz geschehen kann ich voll in der Obersten Liga mitspielen, kein Problem.
Ja, ich bin ja leider ferngeblieben, aber wir kommen gleich zu den Konferenzen. Ich ich habe so ein bisschen schlechtes Gewissen. Ich will einmal noch ein Feedback vorlesen,
was ich jetzt irgendwie ich glaub ein oder zwei Folgen schon vergessen habe und das,
Das äh finde ich schade, deswegen würde ich das jetzt einmal ganz schnell hinter mich bringen, weil ich so,
ganz panisch bin. Und zwar haben wir eine anonyme Zuschrift bekommen.
Lautete und da ging es um ähm die Flugzeug äh Sicherheit und zwar das
ne, weil das jetzt hier diskutiert wurde, okay, wir lassen uns doch die,
fernsteuern, während mein Einwand war, dann wird der Terrorist nicht mehr da drin sitzen, sondern fernsteuern,
Ähm und da haben wir auch über die Firewall und Netzwerksysteme in den Flugzeugen gesprochen.
Da wurde ja auch, da wurde, wurde ja auch heiß diskutiert äh und uns auch teilweise ähm Realitätsferne vorgeworfen. In den Kommentaren.
Genau, ja, Realitätsfern sind wir ja ohnehin. Wir haben ja Ideale. Das ist ja also viel weiter von der Realität kann's ja gar nicht wäch.
Aber okay, hier kam jetzt mal jemand mit Kompetenz und der schrieb ähm also unter anonym ähm,
Kabinennetz und Cockpitnetz waren bis vor ein paar Jahren durch eine Firewall getrennt. In diesem Fall meinte er also eine,
dedizierte Appliance Firewall. Inzwischen werden die unterschiedlichen Systeme wie auch die Firewall virtualisiert auf gemeinsamer Hardwarebetrieb,
Das ist eine eine sehr ähm aus ökonomischer Perspektive sicherlich sehr zu,
begrüßende, also und auch aus Stromverbrauchs äh Fragen sehr zu begrüßende Entwicklung. Aus äh aus Fragen der IT-Sicherheit natürlich eher äh etwas Unheilige, äh Entwicklung, dass man eben mehr und mehr einfach virtualisiert,
dann quasi alles auf einem Gerät laufen hat, aber in verschiedenen virtuellen Containern. Blöd ist natürlich, wenn dann halt,
wenn diese Virtualisierung nicht vernünftig funktioniert und da einer irgendwie rausklettert oder es schafft
ein den den Hypervisor abzuschalten, dann ist halt auch direkt alles kaputt. Aber okay,
Weiter geht's, die Begründung für den Netzzugriff im Cockpit,
Entertainment-System muss die aktuellen Flugdaten erhalten, um sie.
Die Flugroute auf der Landkarte, ne, also hat man bei also, wenn es kein innereuropäischer Flug ist, hat man das,
ab zwei, drei Stunden Flügen hast du ja nicht immer so einen kleinen Fernseher,
regelmäßig die Kameras durch und dann siehst du, jetzt fliegt er da lang und dann siehst du da, ah München, München ist lang
und äh ja dann siehst du von oben und dann kommt dann, dann kommt wieder so eine Animation mit der Welt, Kugel und so. Und dafür muss das Flugzeug natürlich auch genau wissen, wo es ist und deswegen dieses GPS wird da durchgegeben,
Offenbar ist bislang niemandem,
niemandem die Idee gekommen, dem Kabinennetz einen eigenen GPS-Empfänger zu spendieren und die Leitung zu kappen.
Also stimmt tatsächlich, das Kabinennetz und das Cockpitnetz sind erstmal nur durch eine äh Firewall getrennt.
Gab es.
Das ist äh um dann vielleicht nochmal kurz nachzuhacken. Also.
Jetzt fällt mir sicherlich gleich die Argumente kommen, dass wenn du jetzt wirklich all diese ganzen Flugdaten und wann kommen wir denn voraussichtlich an und so weiter. Ich meine, da reicht ja ein GPS-Empfänger nicht. Ne, also ist ja sozusagen es gibt da schon aufbereitete Informationen, die quasi
teilweise wohl im Flugzeug generiert werden, teilweise vielleicht auch von außen kommen.
Müsste sich halt schon Gedanken darüber machen, auch so etwas entsprechend zu
ähm so in der Logik eines Flugzeugbauers ist das natürlich schon etwas, wo dann die Ökonomie,
ähm sich durchsetzt, nachvollziehbarer Prozess so von außen, aber natürlich nicht ohne Sicherheitsimplikationen, das muss man sich schon klar machen und auch solche
Trennung, was es ja gerade schon gesagt hat, sollte man es nochmal kurz aufschlüsseln,
also sozusagen wenn zwei Systeme auf dem selben Computer laufen, als wären sie eigentlich zwei Computer,
aber es ist eben jetzt auch noch nicht so, dass äh man nicht schon auch dort Sicherheitslücken entdeckt hätte. Auch das ist
durchaus alles schon mal irgendwo gebrochen und die grundsätzliche Annahme, dass sowas per se sicherer sei als eine Firewall oder so äh ist einfach eine Fehlernahme. Und in dem Moment, wo halt zwischen diesen beiden virtuellen Systemen auch noch Daten ausgetauscht werden
ist es quasi wie, ja, ein Kabel zwischen zwei Rechnern und was das für Implikationen haben kann,
das äh sind wir ja täglich im Netz.
Jo
Dann gab's zur zur letzten Folge noch eine Ergänzung von ähm äh Herr oder Frau Feuerwasser. Äh dass Betroffene von polizeilichen Abhörmaßnahmen informiert werden müssen,
wenn das Verfahren abgeschlossen ist. Das gibt es auch schon in Deutschland.
Praktisch, findest das aber so gut wie nicht statt. Denn da schreibt dann ein Beamter einfach einen Vermerk Restwahrscheinlichkeit oder Restrisiko, dass da doch noch etwas zu finden sein könnte.
Und um eventuelle zukünftige Verfahren nicht jetzt schon zu gefährden, wird dann halt lieber noch nicht informiert,
Also das heißt, informiert über eine Abhörmaßnahme wirst du erst dann, wenn.
Sie mit absoluter Sicherheit sagen können, okay, der ist diese Zielperson ist absolut unschuldig und wir haben keinen keinerlei Restwahrscheinlichkeit, dass wir die irgendwann nochmal abhören wollen.
Deswegen können wir sie jetzt auch darüber in Kenntnis setzen. Und man kann sich natürlich vorstellen, dass diese polizeilichen Abhörmaßnahmen natürlich eher dann angeordnet werden.
Wenn man irgendwie eine Form von Verdacht hat, ja und dann,
weiß man ja auch, wie Polizisten mit dem Ausräumen von Verdacht,
einräumen von Verdächtigungen und insofern äh kann man sich das sehr gut vorstellen, dass dann ähm entsprechend relativ wenig Menschen auch nur darüber in Kenntnis gesetzt werden, dass sie abgehört wurden, weil man weiß ja nicht, ob man die nicht vielleicht doch nochmal,
am Telefon einmal vom vom Joint erzählt, ja, vielleicht müssen wir da nochmal bei.
Sind ja schon mal einmal bei uns in den Fokus gekommen, dann muss da ja auch, vielleicht kann da mal auch was dran sein.
Den gab's immerhin schon polizeiliche Ermittlungen.
Genau, sogar von uns, ja? Also äh man kann wahrscheinlich davon ausgehen, dass wenn die zuständigen Beamten dann in Rente gegangen sind, dass der Fall dann auch final abgeschlossen ist.
Aus Polizeiperspektive muss man auch dazu sagen, ist das natürlich ein Stück weit auch,
nachvollziehbar, ja? Manchmal hast du vielleicht einen Hinweis, dann schaffst du halt eine eine Maßnahme
Und vielleicht hattest du so, sagen wir mal, die entscheidende Nebeninformation noch nicht, um da jetzt auch wirklich auf eine richtige Spur zu kommen, da wäre das natürlich äh aus taktischer Sicht etwas töricht vorschnell
dem Überwachten quasi so, ach ja übrigens, wir haben dich jetzt mal überwacht, äh packe jetzt mal, verbrenne jetzt mal alle, alle Ordner,
äh also ich kann das ein Stück weit nachvollziehen. Sicherlich,
muss man dort aber einen Modus finden, der dann eben diese Auskunft,
Pflicht dann auch zu einem Zeitpunkt dann auch aktiviert, die,
angemessen ist.
So ist es. Und dann haben wir noch einen kurze einen kurzen Aufruf und zwar ähm wurden wir angesprochen von jemandem, der gerne mit seinem D-Mail-Konto mal was ausprobieren würde,
aber leider niemanden kennt, der auch eins hat.
Bitte melde dich.
Der Hörer, falls sich unter der Hörerschaft jemand befindet, der, der oder die jetzt mal die Gelegenheit ergreifen möchte, die erste D-Mail,
des Lebens zu schreiben so, ihr habt jetzt die Gelegenheit ähm,
wendet euch dann bitte mal vertrauensvoll an mich über das äh Kontaktformular verlinkt, in den,
Shownotes, dann stelle ich da gerne äh den Kontakt her und dann könnt ihr meine,
eine D-Mail schreiben, solange das noch kostenlos ist,
Wobei da noch der Hinweis, die werden natürlich immer kostenlos sein. Das wird dir, kannst du jetzt nicht irgendwann nochmal Geld dafür nehmen. Das ist natürlich totaler Quatsch. Also das Ding ist tot, aber wer nochmal versuchen möchte, das Pferd zu reiten oder wenigstens einmal erzählen möchte, damals, als ich eine D-Mail schrieb
Jetzt ist die Gelegenheit, wir machen jetzt hier so ein eine DBL-Kontaktbörse.
Zum.
D-Mail-Freundschaft, wer eine D-Mail-Freundschaft haben möchte.
Ja, ich meine, vielleicht wäre das ja auch noch ein Weg, das,
Ja? Äh,
lerne, lerne, lerne jetzt äh andere Leute in deiner Nachbarschaft kennen, die auch mit dem Finanzamt kommunizieren wollen.
Jetzt auf der.
Wollen vertraulich kommunizieren.
Hände zu Ende verschlüsselst.
Oh Gott. Na ja, also warum nicht? Ja, also vielleicht können wir ja nochmal ein richtig schönes Social Netzwerk äh draus machen, dass die paar Leute, die da noch dabei sind, sich zumindest auch noch mal kennengelernt haben, bevor es abgeschaltet wird,
Sowas.
Kann man okay. Na komme mal, kommen wir mal zu den zu den ernsten Themen.
Republika. Ich konnte ja leider nicht. Ich hatte es ja gesagt, ich bin ja aus Solidarität mit den Lokführern und den Bestreikten gleichermaßen bin ich dieses Jahr nicht zur Republika gegangen.
Verzichtet, Solidarität.
Mhm. Ja. Da hofft man natürlich immer, dass es scheiße wird.
Genau die verpasst hat, die die doof war. Aber da war ich ja schon nicht mehr dabei und so,
Es gibt sicherlich ein paar valide Kritikpunkte an der Republika insgesamt,
Was aber mal wieder ein schönes äh Treffen, denn wie so für viele andere Konferenzen gilt, am Ende geht man ja dahin
um äh Menschen zu treffen und zu sprechen und Ideen und Projekte und keine Ahnung, was äh auszutauschen. Und das konnte man aber auch wieder äh auch in diesem Jahr wieder trefflich äh tun auf dem großen Hof äh
verbringt man dann halt dann relativ viel Zeit. Es gibt natürlich auch Leute, die sehr viel Zeit in,
den Besuch von Vorträgen investieren, da gehörte ich in eingeschränkten Maße dazu, ich hab
sagen wir mal so ein bisschen meine Spezialthemen,
Äh sprich äh alles Podcast spezifische versucht ähm abzuklappern. Da gab's ja so einiges dieses Jahr,
Aber dann gibt's ja auch noch so unglaublich viel anderes dort und das kann einem immer schnell äh überlasten und irgendwann ist so ein Tag ja auch zu Ende.
Der Astronaut war da, ne? Alexander Gerst.
Alexander Gerst, das habe ich auch noch kurz gesehen,
den Weg so,
So ein Event zu sein, der auf einer breiten Basis versucht gesellschaftliche Anregungen auszuspucken. Das sage ich mal so. Äh aus meiner Beobachtung, denn es ist,
generell schon so ein bisschen schwierig geworden die Frage ja was ist denn die Republika eigentlich irgendwie mit mit einem Satz zu beantworten?
Auf Spiegel Online steht immer Netzkonferenz, Republika.
Ja gut, Netzkonferenz, aber ich meine, geht's noch generischer? Ja, also das, das, das ist halt ähm,
Ein sehr äh weites Feld, so also man,
netzpolitischen Aspekten,
aus technischen Sachen
weniger, aber sagen wir mal Businesstrends spielen da eine Rolle, ähm technische Trends im Sinne von, was halt äh Anwendungen, Netzwerke und ähnliche ähm Dienste sind, die jetzt ein besonderes Interesse erzeugen.
Man merkt schon, letztlich natürlich, wer auch äh hinter der Republika Orga steht und das ist ja halt äh in einer Hinsicht eben,
Und ähm letzten Endes auch das ganze Team von Netzpolitik org. Das merkt man einfach, dass,
der netzpolitische Bereich oder der sagen wir mal, überhaupt der politische Bereich, der einfach hochkarätig,
vertreten ist. Ich muss zugeben, dass ich jetzt zu diesem Zeitpunkt noch nicht sehr viele,
geben kann, weil ich einfach jetzt noch nicht alles gesehen habe. Ich habe von einigen Sachen gehört, die ganz gut gewesen sein sollen, aber die werde ich jetzt mal hier nicht groß anpreisen, bevor ich da nicht selber nochmal einen Blick drauf gemacht habe, also stellt euch nächste Woche noch mal auf einen kleinen äh Veranstaltungsrückblick ein
ansonsten ähm,
Fand ich ja mal wieder ganz interessant. Ich meine, die Eigenwahrnehmung ist ja immer ein bisschen schwierig, wenn man auf so einem Event,
jahrelang gewesen ist, ich hab glaub ich keine Republik ausgelassen nächstes Jahr ist ja dann die,
die Zehnte schon angesagt. Ähm.
Dann hat man natürlich schnell das Gefühl, so oh Gott, es ist alles so groß geworden. Und das ist auch von mir persönlich durchaus ein Kritikpunkt. Ich finde, es gibt einfach viel zu viele Sessions. Es ist
Es ist so breit gestreut, dass es einfach den Fokus äh verliert. Also wenn wenn man wirklich jeden irgendwie äh noch unterbekommt, dann ist natürlich auch die Auswahl des Programms irgendwo knifflig. Trotzdem gibt's halt immer wieder,
gute Highlights, man würde sich bloß manchmal wünschen, es ist etwas verdichteterweise mit irgendwie zwölf Bühnen und so weiter, da da wird man halt auch irgendwann äh kirre, so.
Also diese ich war äh zwei Sachen, die mir dazu kurz einfallen. Ähm,
drei sogar. Erstens, äh die Republik wird nicht nur von New Thinking gemacht, sondern auch von Spreeblick, nicht, dass die nachher beleidigt sind.
Äh ja, entschuldigen. Da wollte ich noch drauf kommen, also genau.
Ah okay. Dann ähm finde ich dieses ähm,
Veranstaltung gehst, ne? Du hast jetzt gerade erzählt, uns vorher unterhalten haben, auch schon,
angesprochen, ne? Also die Leute, die auf so Businessmessen oder sowas gehen, ne, für die ist die Republika,
nach wie vor irgendwie so ein absolutes Hardcore-Independent-Ding, ne, also die ähm,
Wenn ihr jetzt mal auf so eine DMEX-Ko oder sowas gehst, ne, das sind halt irgendwelche Business-Veranstaltungen, davon ist die Republika immer noch meilenweit entfernt. Ich glaube, da muss man nochmal so ein, ein Norden, auch aus welcher Perspektive wir denn da vielleicht drauf blicken,
die jetzt wie du halt über Jahrzehnte inzwischen mit dem mit dem CCC Kongress involviert sind, wo es,
also wo es ähm wo Sponsoren eben auch ihre Slots bekommen. Da da sponsert dann halt Daimler und erzählt dann kriegt halt äh Tag eins, Bühne eins
und erzählt über wie das Auto der Zukunft, ne? So.
Genau.
Die können aber auch nicht auf so viele Freiwillige zurückgreifen, wie der, wie der Kongress. Ähm.
Also um das gleich klarzustellen, es sind auch schon mal Sponsoren,
sehr wohl also sind sehr wohl Sponsoren genannt worden im Rahmen des.
Am Ende, das stimmt, ja.
Das bezieht sich meistens auf Netzwerkequipment und so weiter. Das ist auch in Ordnung,
aber es ist halt nicht so, dass es da irgendwelche Gold-Premiumabteilungen gibt und schon gar nicht, dass man sich in irgendeiner Form als Teil des Programms äh einkauft oder auch nur visuell in irgendeiner Form sichtbar ist auf diesem Event. Das ist halt ein Spezifikum des Kongresses. Das kann nicht jeder machen, das ist vollkommen nachvollziehbar.
Frage ist natürlich wirklich, wie weit dickt das eben ein und
generell immer das Problem, wenn man halt mit mit Werbung Sponsoring arbeitet, inwiefern verfälscht es deine eigene Botschaft. Das ist halt jetzt mal äh
Von der anderen Seite sieht,
war ganz interessant so auch Feedback zu sammeln von Leuten, die äh sagen wir mal viel auch so im normalen Schlips-Business unterwegs sind, aber eben auch Teil der Republika schon immer waren in dieser Szene. Die meinten dann halt so, na ja, also äh hier meine Kollegen, die hier irgendwie aufgelaufen sind, die die
die laufen ja immer noch äh äh rum, als würden sie sich in,
Weltraum befinden. Also für die ist es irgendwie äh vollkommen,
nur mit Schnappatmung äh zu kommentieren, wie's da halt zugeht, für die ist das eine totale Freakshow, sind aber auch vollkommen begeistert und auf der anderen Seite, wenn dann halt, ist jetzt ein interessanter Effekt, ne, wenn die dann sehen, so, oh hier, Daimler und die,
große, große Unternehmen sind hier irgendwie Teil dieses Events, präsentieren sich hier auf die ein oder andere Form.
Äh ja, das sind so unsere potenziellen Kunden und die sind auch hier, da,
da verschiebt sich irgendwie was im Hirn. Also das passt irgendwie erstmal nicht so in ihre Welt rein. Und ähm das das kann auch ein positiver Aspe
Ich meine, das ist alles immer noch sehr entschlips. Das ist irgendwie äh Casual Dress ist da einfach äh die Normalität auf der Republika,
glaube, ich habe nicht eine Krawatte gesehen auf diesem ganzen Event und da waren wahrscheinlich wieder, keine Ahnung, sechstausend Leute.
Ähm der aber äh das will das genau jetzt das war der Aspekt, den ich noch ansprechen wollte. Ich glaube echt, dass also Business ist da, Business würde ich da echt nicht sagen. Ich würde sagen.
Was die Republika macht ist,
Politik. Also sie hat eine sehr klare netzpolitische Einordnung. Klar, das wäre alles andere wäre sehr verwunderlich. Und eigentlich Netzkultur.
Oder? Also ich meine, das ist halt wirklich Netzkultur, der da Open Data und solche solche Sachen spielen da alle immer eine große eine große Rolle. Und natürlich dann auch irgendwelche.
Ähm ähm Konsumententechnologiephilosophen, die sich dann irgendwie Gedanken darüber machen, wie,
ähm das ist schon an vielen, an vielen äh Bereichen schon sehr interessant,
das äh das denke ich schon, dass das dass das,
von den Vorträgen her eine eine Reise wert ist, wenn auch ich bin gleich ich immer den den Hof auch eher bevorzuge. Das mache ich bei anderen Veranstaltungen genauso. Ähm.
Was die ähm Ansammlung des äh oder was die Beliebigkeit des Programms angeht mit der,
Menge an ähm die es dort gibt ähm muss man auch wissen, die haben glaube ich auch nochmal.
Ich habe letztens mal irgendwo die Zahl gehört, der Einreichung bei der Republika,
die ist, glaube ich, noch mal um einiges höher als beim Kongress.
Ja
Aber dann müsste, glaube ich, aber ich glaube, dass sich die Quote der angenommenen Vorträge, die es wiederum sehr viel.
Viel größer beim Kongress, werden aber wiederum die absolute Anzahl an abgelehnter,
Einreichung wieder höher ist, dadurch dass sie so viele Stages haben.
Also weißt du, man kann da nicht sagen, dass das jetzt so besonders beliebig wäre, also da da reinzukommen, hast bist du trotzdem noch und da liest du trotzdem noch eine
sehr viel größeren Wahrscheinlich, wenn du dich, wenn du da einreißt, unterliest du immer noch einer sehr viel größeren Wahrscheinlichkeit, abgelehnt zu werden, als angenommen zu werden.
Ja, also so oder so, man merkt, das Interesse ist auf jeden Fall da noch lange nicht äh Alarm und da geht eine Menge und man lernt eine Menge Leute äh nette Leute,
Eine Menge netter Leute kennen, das ist noch zu früh.
Und zwei Vorträge können wir, glaube ich, schon mal noch empfehlen. Einmal ähm unser Thomas hat einen Vortrag gehalten zur Netznetralität. Das hat er, glaube ich, auch in der letzten,
gehalten, das war auch spannend. Die beiden verlinken wir hier an der Stelle.
Okay. Äh Thomas Vortrag habe ich auch gesehen, der war wirklich gut. Da kommen wir dann auch gleich nochmal auf ein anderes Detail am Ende. Ja, wollen wir mal in unser Programm einsteigen.
Ja ähm.
Abkommen. Das Noespy-Abkommen, wir hatten es ja schon fast vergessen.
Wir hatten das ja schon fast vergessen. Ähm.
Erinnerst du dich?
Ja, aber ich äh noch lebendige Erinnerungen irgendwie. Das äh war doch der, der das Ende der der äh der gesamten Überwachungs-Affäre gleich zum zu Beginn.
Genau, da war die ja vorbei, schon.
Da war das dann einfach durch das Thema.
Also genau, als die Geheimdienst-Affäre vorbei war, ja, im Sommer zweitausenddreizehn.
Ähm gab es ja dann die die Diskussion um ein Norteabkommen, das die Bundesregierung jetzt fordern würde und dann äh haben sie später auch eine Zusage der USA bekannt gegeben.
Süddeutsche, dieser Rechercheverbund von Süddeutsche Zeitung, NDR und WDR. Da mal so ein paar ähm geheime Dokumente sich angeschaut und da geht es hauptsächlich um die Kommunikation zwischen Merkels Außenpolitischen Berater Christoph Heusgen.
Und um E Obamas, ehemaliger Chefstrategin für Europa, Caron Don
nächsten äh oder ne Berater, die die da so dranstehen,
nie in Themenbereichen und die führen natürlich dann so, die schreiben sich dann halt Mails oder so, ne?
Und das Schöne ist, ähm während es um diese,
als die Deutschen dann anfing, mit ey lass mal ein Abkommen machen, ähm,
Hat Donfried natürlich gesagt, ja, äh also sie haben den mehrmals vertröstet und hat erklärt, sie müssten die rechtliche Grundlage für eine solche Zusage prüfen.
Abkommen sollte ja beinhalten, dass wenn die NSA auf deutschem Boden,
spioniert, sie sich an die an die an geltendes Recht in Deutschland hält. Das war das Noseabkommen, das war der Inhalt, ja? Und.
Es ist natürlich.
Sie erstmal nachschauen, ob ihnen das überhaupt.
Schreibt dir jemand, der schreibt dir, der schreibt dir die die,
die Chefstrategin für Europa,
von den USA sagt dir, du sagst ihnen, hey, können wir nicht ein Abkommen unterzeichnen, dass ihr uns an die Gesetz, dass ihr euch an unsere Gesetze haltet, wenn ihr in unserem Land spioniert und die sagen,
Sorry, ich weiß überhaupt nicht, ob wir da eine rechtliche Grundlage für haben. Schön. So,
schreibst dir, also das wird halt so ein bisschen schöner aus diesen E-Mails zitiert. Er schreibt sie am nächsten Tag, sie habe betrübliche Nachrichten.
Jeder versteht natürlich die schwierige Lage der Kanzlerin. Die Frage, ob deutsches Recht auf deutschem Boden respektiert wird,
Interpretation der deutschen Gesetze unter Einschaltung von,
Herten geklärt werden. Hier liegt der Fokus natürlich darauf, ob wir das US-Recht einhalten,
Experten fühlen sich nicht dafür gerüstet die Einhaltung des deutschen Rechts zu beurteilen.
Sagt die, nachdem sie zu dem Zeitpunkt haben sie, glaube ich, ähm,
Elf Jahre Zusammenarbeit in Bad Aibling. Ja, und dann sagen die, hör mal, unsere Anwälte sind dafür da, ähm,
ähm dass das US-Recht zu biegen, aber doch nicht das Deutsche, so. Da sind die haben die das sollen die gar nicht studiert, dann müssen die erstmal ein Auslandssemester machen.
Das ist so super.
Schreibt der Heuskin sofort zurück ähm ja ähm,
die Experten aus unseren Ministerien können euch ja unterstützen,
Achtung der deutschen Gesetze auf deutschem Boden bleibt die Schlüsselfrage und dann sagen sie ähm gibt's denn eine interne Mail aus dem
ohne das Wissen der deutschen Sicherheit, Sicherheitsdienste und gerade da wollen wir sie ja auf deutsches Recht verpflichten,
wenn wir sie schon nicht kontrollieren können.
Ist das erbärmlich. So und Anfang August.
Da haben wir auch drüber berichtet, reisten dann die Chefs von Verfassungsschutz, Bundesnachrichtendienst,
Innenministerium in die USA, das war haben wir auch ausführlich darüber berichtet und trafen da NSA-Chef Kiew Alexander und James Klepper
nachher auch nochmal eine Rolle spielen wird, der Direktor der Z,
also eigentlich quasi der der Oberchef der Geheimdienste, ja? Der führt alle Geheimdienste, ähm die Reporten quasi an ihn.
Also wahrscheinlich mehr mehr so ein mehr so ein Koordinator für die ganzen Geheimdienste, weil die natürlich für sich genommen sehr autark arbeiten.
Fünf Seiten, ganz schön witzig, wenn man sich überlegt, wie viele Leute dahin geflogen sind, aber okay. Fünf Seiten BND-Protokoll, ähm.
Da wird eine angebliche erste Annäherung festgehalten. NSA-Chef Alex Sender habe beschwichtigt, Deutschland sei doch kein Zielland. Ähm,
und Klepper sagt ähm überrascht mit einem Vorstoß, er könne sich die Bildung einer Arbeitsgruppe vorstellen.
Und zwar nach dem Vorbild der Abhöranlage in Bad Aibling zweitausendzwölf.
Äh zweitausendzwei, Entschuldigung. Das ist genau die, wo wir jetzt grade noch den anderen Skandal wegen der Selektoren haben, nur mal so als Beispiel, ne, wo das ist aber das Thema, wo wir nachher zu kommen, da muss man sich alles so ein bisschen auseinanderhalten,
Und äh bei Bad Aibling hieß es, hier gab es ja, dass Memor random of Agreement, ja, wir halten uns an deutsches Recht. Was sie dann einfach nicht getan haben, ja. Das war der, das war das, was der,
was der Klepper da mal angedeutet hat. Ähm man könnte eben ein solches Abkommen für ganz Deutschland ähm.
Treffen. Er selbst,
darüber aber keine ad hoc Entscheidung treffen. Er habe keine Prokura, denn das Ganze ist eine politische Frage,
Die Antwort liegt im weißen Haus. Das heißt, der hat gesagt, na ja, man könnte sich ja vorstellen, das funktioniert ja eigentlich ganz gut mit dem Member Random of Agreement, weil da müssen wir uns ja nicht dran halten,
Deswegen könnten wir das eigentlich auch gerne für ganz Deutschland machen, aber ich habe da sowieso gar keine Entscheidungshoheit. Und dann Mitte August, als sie zurückkam,
trat hier unser Pofalla roll der Typ ey. Trat dann vor die vor die Medien und sagte ja,
Wir haben eine Zusage der US-Seite für ein no Spy-Abkommen, ich erkläre die Affäre hiermit für beendet.
Steffen Seibert, Regierungssprecher, der übrigens immer noch Regierungssprecher ist, der hat noch nicht in irgendwie in die Wirtschaft gewechselt.
Kommt ja aus der Wirtschaftszahl aus der Medienwirtschaft. Also aus.
Aber man geht ja dann auch irgendwann. Man geht ja dann, genau das ist ja nicht Wirtschaft,
Öffentlich-Rechtliche, ich bitte dich. Ähm das, also das ist ja nicht Wirtschaft, wenn du also Wirtschaft ist ja, wenn du ähm deine Kunden
mehr oder weniger lauteren Mitteln überzeugen muss für dein Produkt zu bezahlen. Und das ist ja bei bei öffentlich rechtlichen nicht der Fall.
Aber okay, das ist eine, das ist eine das ist eine Rand.
So, also.
Seibert sagte, es wird ein Abkommen geben.
Dann schrieb, ähm Häuschen an Donfred.
Ja äh hi äh und so, ne? Was die Vereinbarung angeht, wäre es echt großartig, wenn sie irgendwie öffentlich den Beginn solcher Gespräche oder Verhandlungen loben könnten, das wäre für uns,
extrem hilfreich.
Schreibt,
schreibt der der außenpolitische Berater von Merkel, an die an die,
Chefkoordinatorin von Obama. So, ja. Eine, eine.
So behält da rum, so wir wir haben hier die großen Schuhe an und müssen ein Feuer austreten, es wäre echt hilfreich, wenn ihr einfach nur sagen könntet, dass wir uns unterhalten, ja?
Dann kommt von der US-Botschaft, also von äh dem Gebäude in,
in Berlin neben dem Brandenburger Tor, von wo aus äh so der Verdacht ja die ähm die ähm nahe Radio Radiosignalüberwachung der der deutschen Parlaments und Regierungsgebäude stattfindet. Ähm,
Beschwerde, denn Hans-Peter Friedrich, damals noch Innenminister,
der hat ja jetzt zurück in die Landwirtschaft gewechselt oder so, ne? Aber egal. Friedrich hatte gesagt, wir haben die Zusage, dass ein solches Abkommen bald geschlossen werden kann.
Und der stellvertretende Leiter der US-Botschaft in Berlin, Jim schrieb an Holskin, Christoph Holsken. Guten Morgen Christoph.
Ich habe mich über die Bemerkung von Friedrich gewundert. Das wird Washington noch mehr verwirren.
Ich sag's Papi.
Also mit anderen Worten.
Also die diplomatisch in der Diplomatie ist es ja immer sehr, sehr wichtig, dass die enorm höflich sprechen. Und kleine äh Verstöße des Protokolls in der Diplomatie sind ja schon ähm,
Also es sind ja dann so Affronts, ne, also irgendwie sowas wie
ich komme wegen Krankheiten nicht zu der Konferenz oder so. Das sind ja dann das sind ja dann schon Direktskandale, weil man eben auf diese auf dieser Ebene sich nicht die Blöße geben kann, emotional zu sprechen. Man vertritt eben einen ganzen Staat und das muss man dann eben
diplomatisch tun. Ist ja auch in Ordnung so.
Wenn man da jetzt mal zwischen den Zeilen liest, ja, das ist halt das diplomatische Äquivalent von,
Oktober, im Oktober kam dann das Merkel-Handy raus, ne? Das also das ist noch dazu zu sagen.
Ich finde, ich finde das auch so bemerkenswert. Ja, dass dass sie sich äh,
Auch in die Öffentlichkeit getraut haben, ohne wirklich so eine Absicherung nach hinten zu haben, ja. Macht so ein bisschen so den Eindruck, als ob er irgendwie so zur zur Botschaft gegangen ist
Und dann so am am Zaun mit irgendwie so ein Sicherheitspersonal, Menschen,
hat. Weißt du so, das ist so der Grad an Absicherung.
Die haben einfach gelogen. Tim, die haben einfach gelogen. Das äh die haben einfach gelogen. Und zwar auch wissentlich und der aus dem einfachen, aus dem einfachen Grund, dass sie wissen, okay, selbst wenn das zwei Jahre später rauskommt,
kriegen wir haben wir netto immer noch Schaden verhindert?
Und genau das wird jetzt passieren. Im Oktober kam dann dieser ganze Merkel-Handy-Skandal, dann abhören unter Freunden geht gar nicht und so,
und im Januar zweitausendvierzehn hat dann der der liebe Christoph Häuskin,
einer erneuten ähm individuellen Erniedrigung,
letzten Versuch unternommen Januar siebter Januar.
Liebe Karen.
Am Donnerstag habe ich einen, habe ich ein erstes Treffen mit unserem neuen Kanzleramtsminister Altmaier und dem neuen Koordinator der Geheimdienste, Staatssekretär Fritsche.
Mein erster Eindruck in den hatte, ähm hatte. Mein erster Eindruck in den ersten Gesprächen mit den beiden ist folgender.
Text erfüllt unsere Erwartungen nicht, weil er die Möglichkeit nicht ausschließt, dass die USA deutsche Bürger ohne unsere Zustimmung und ohne unser Wissen aussperren. In Klammern,
und er kriegt einen halben Tag später die Antwort von Karin Don.
Ich kann sie nicht korrigieren, da sie recht haben. Dies wird kein Abkommen werden und ich glaube, jeder hier auf unserer Seite hat das auch.
Jederzeit fortwährend zum Ausdruck gebracht.
Das ist der, das ist eben das, das diplomatische äh Äquivalent von.
Fuck you.
Gar nichts mehr sagen. Bist du. Und Christoph Heusken erklärt den Kampf um ein No-Spy-Abkommen für beendet und schreibt an,
ja? Ich verspreche diesen Ausdruck künftig nicht mehr zu verwenden.
Oh Mann.
Das ist wirklich, wirklich krass. Ende vom Lied war dann Steinmeier war dann Ende Februar zweitausendvierzehn nochmal in Washington.
Und gab dann nachher bekannt, er war dankbar für die Bereitschaft der Amerikaner zu einem gemeinsamen
Cyber-Dialog unter Beteiligung der Wissenschaft und der Zivilgesellschaft. Da habe ich, glaube ich, ähm im Deutschlandfunk damals morgens um sieben oder was äh zu kommentiert. Ähm.
Das da war dann auch das Gelächter ziemlich groß. Ähm als,
Aber also der die also nicht über das, was ich gesagt habe, sondern über das, was da geschehen ist,
Ja, ich meine, die haben einfach gelogen, fertig.
Ja und vor allem habe ich auch so den Eindruck, dass sie.
Sie haben nicht nur äh gelogen, Sie haben, sagen wir mal, entgegen den diplomatischen Interessen der USA gehandelt. Sie haben,
ja, es ist ja nicht so, dass gemeinsam mit ihnen gelogen hätten, jetzt wahrscheinlich keinen interessiert, sondern sie haben halt so äh ja, wir behaupten jetzt einfach mal, die Amerikaner hätten das und das,
zugesagt, obwohl sie es nicht haben, was natürlich dann auch nochmal zu einer
Ja, ja. Weiteren,
eigentlich auch alles in die falsche Richtung geht. So, ich meine, dieser Unmut hätte sich ja sehr viel mehr von Deutscher in Richtung USA-Seite entfalten müssen. Stattdessen müssen sie sich jetzt noch klein mit Hut äh zusammenfalten lassen.
Das ist schon 'ne ziemlich absurde Situation und zeigt natürlich auch wie das Kräfteverhältnis hier an der Stelle ist.
Das ist äh äh also ich finde daran genau zwei Sachen bemerkenswert. Einmal, dass sie, dass sie lügen, okay, darüber könnten wir uns jetzt äh aufregen, aber man merkt irgendwie, dass da auch jetzt so wirklich überrascht auch kaum noch jemand ist.
Zweitens, dass sie dass sie so blöd sind, dass.
Sogar zu machen und der uns irgendwie offensichtlich einerseits versuchen, auf die Amerikaner dadurch Druck auszuüben.
Und sich andererseits halt zu absolut arschkriecherisch, den den Amerikanern gegenüber am Ende noch dafür ähm entschuldigen,
müssen, ja, weil sie halt weil sie halt sich da verrannt haben. Und das ist natürlich schon wirklich da ist man jetzt nicht ähm.
Stolz drauf, wenn die, wenn die Angestellten von gewählten Vertretern ähm in dieser Form halt meinen Interessen zu vertreten, ne.
Das ist schon ein bisschen erbärmlich, finde ich.
Ciao. Tatsache ist,
um es mal zusammenzufassen, dieser ganze Notekram war einfach nichts anderes als eine,
Ablenkungsversuch der Öffentlichkeit, so eine kleine Nebelwolke, die man gezündet hat, um irgendwie so den Eindruck zu ähm,
Regen,
in so einem Schock so oh Gott, ach nee, also das tut uns jetzt aber wirklich leid, da sind wir wohl ein bisschen zu weit gegangen, hätten halt jetzt irgendwie zugesagt, dass er das jetzt so nicht mehr machen würden.
Von es war
ja? Man kann davon ausgehen, äh in zunehmendem Maße, denke ich, wird das auch so durch die ganze Faktenlage nahegelegt.
Die Bundesregierung war sich immer vollkommen bewusst, wie der Hase läuft. Sie haben selber zusammengearbeitet,
komme jetzt auch gleich nochmal im Detail drauf. Äh über Jahre. Es ist eine totale Normalität,
aber eben mit sehr äh einem sehr asymmetrischen Grundverhältnis. Und.
Deutschland wird dich in dem Maße ein nutzen aus dieser Zusammenarbeit äh gezogen hat, wie es die USA gezogen hat, darf glaube ich bezweifelt werden.
Ja zeigte auch der BND Untersuchungsausschuss, der jetzt in der letzten Woche stand,
hat. Da waren ähm.
Zwei Personen,
EU, der war schon zum zweiten Mal da, DB, der war zum ersten Mal da,
dann auch nochmal der äh Gerhard Schindler, der aber nur in der nichtöffentlichen,
Sitzung alle drei vom BND, Gerd Schindler, natürlich dessen,
Präsident. Und da ähm der EU,
dann gefragt, ja haben sie sich denn schon mal mit der, mit Selektorenlisten beschäftigt? Und dann sagt der, jein.
Jein. Fragt dann auch noch so nach so, tschuldigung, was ne? Dann sagt er, ja, also die Kontrolle dieser sogenannten Selektoren ist ja nicht unser Job.
Denn das war also jemand, das war der Direktor von Bad Aibling, wenn ich mich nicht täusche,
Warum sollten wir da nochmal draufschauen? Bad Aibling holt die diese Selektoren mehrfach am Tag,
von über die Datenleitung von den Amerikanern und einmal die Woche gehen sie dann nach Pullach zur Kontrolle und ob da jetzt bestimmte Suchbegriffe ungesetzlich sein könnten, war ihm egal.
Denn er hat Weisungen empfangen. So ERU.
Also dieser RU arbeitet wurde das,
In Bad Aiblingen selber, okay.
Wenn die Zentrale, also in dem Fall die BND Zentrale äh ihnen die Selekturen schickt, das schauen sie sich nicht weiter an, weil es ja die Zentrale und die weiß ja äh alles.
So funktionieren Hierarchien, klar.
Aber sie werden abgeholt von einem amerikanischen Rechner.
Naja, das hatten wir schon öfter besprochen, dass die ähm um das kurz zu ähm nochmal in Erinnerung zu rufen,
das das Setup, was oder das Gebäude, was dir der BND da in Bad Aibling nutzt, gehörte früher der NSA,
als das an an den BND übergeben wurde.
Bunker gebaut, in dem sie drin sitzen. Die beiden,
alte NSA-Gebäude, was sie freundlicherweise dem BND überlassen haben,
und die äh das neue NSA Gebäude, was nebenan ist, verbindet eine Glasfaserleitung und darüber findet einerseits der Austausch der Selektoren, andererseits aber natürlich auch der Austausch der abgefischten Daten statt.
Das heißt, letztendlich hat die hat die äh die NSA ihre alte Anlage ähm,
ihre alte Anlage an einen Dienstleistleister outgesourct, der Dienstleister hieß BND,
und den haben sie halt über eine Glasfaserleitung, die die beiden Gebäude verbannt. Gesagt, hier sucht danach und äh gebe mal die Daten zurück. Und auf beiden fand keinerlei ähm Kontrolle statt.
Und von dort geben sie es dann nach Polar zur Kontrolle und dann legen sie los.
Ändern. Und einmal die Woche wird's nach Pullach geschickt zur Kontrolle. Und wenn Pullach nichts einzuwenden hat, geht's so weiter.
Aber das Entscheidende finde ich vielmehr, was der,
es ist natürlich jetzt einerseits sagt man dann,
kann man sich natürlich jetzt hinsagen und sagen, RU, bist du verrückt? Ähm du bist ja ein unverantwortlicher ähm.
Mensch und du kannst dich ja nicht irgendwie da hinsetzen und alles alle Verantwortungen loswerden, dadurch, dass du Weisungen empfangen hast. Wir haben letzte Woche auch mit Thomas darüber gesprochen, da gibt's ja die entsprechenden Milgrim-Experimente und so, aber so funktionieren Hierarchien halt,
Derjenige, der die Weisung empfangen hat, ist auch von der Verantwortung befreit
des, so werden Menschen in Kriege geschickt, so funktionieren Geheimdienste, so funktionieren Unternehmen. Das ist ganz normal, dass das du ähm dass du weisungsgebunden bist durch eben.
Ähm durch durch äh durch durch bestimmte vertragliche Bindungen und das ist eben
in einer Behörde noch stärker natürlich so als in einem Unternehmen. Aber grundsätzlich,
in fast allen größeren Organisationsformen so, dass es eine Hierarchie gibt und in der werden Verantwortung nach oben gereicht. Und was er jetzt da tut, ist, dass er letzt,
eigentlich durch diese Äußerung, wo er sagt, ist mir egal, ich habe Weisungen bekommen, deutet er schon sehr klar hin, wo die Verantwortung liegt, nämlich nach oben.
Ja? Und da sind wir dann halt relativ bald beim Herrn ähm,
Insofern ist das jetzt einerseits als als Psychogramm ganz interessant,
macht er aber natürlich auch genau das Richtige
aussei, also seine Aussage ist sehr geschickt, weil er sagt, na ja, ich bin weisungsgebunden, die Kontrolle lag an jemand anderem.
Also habe ich einfach gemacht, was mir habe ich diese Praxis aufrecht erhalten. Gleichzeitig.
Deutet sie aber jetzt auch schon so dahin,
sie am Ende sagen werden, naja, ah, hin und her, wir hatten ja diese Vereinbarung und so und dann die die finden jetzt so langsam ihren Weg, wie sie aus der Nummer wieder rauskommen,
Das war nämlich jemand, der.
Tatsächlich problematische Selektoren gefunden hat.
Der auch ein arbeitet.
Ich weiß nicht genau ob der in Bad Aibling oder in Pullach gearbeitet hat ich würde jetzt vermuten in Bad Aibling der meldete nach eigenen Angaben diese problematischen Selektoren.
Aber nicht nach oben und er habe keinem Vorgesetzten informiert. Warum nicht? Wird er dann gefragt? Und da sagt er,
ruft sich auf sein Recht zur Verweigerung der Aussage,
klar, weil er sich damit natürlich eben des ähm,
des Landesverrats äh schuldig gemacht hat und auf jeden Fall irgendwie der irgendwelche Dienstpflich,
verletzt hat, ja. Das heißt, die,
scheinen, sich da unten jetzt schon äh jemanden gefunden zu haben, dem sie jetzt halt irgendwie eine schöne äh schöne Villa in der Karibik angeboten haben
dafür, dass er mal hier ein ein fürs Team nimmt, ne? So würde ich das jetzt mal ähm,
bösartig interpretieren. DB konnte aber eh nicht reden, weil er alle paar Minuten von einem äh Regierungsdirektor des Kanzleramtes unterbrochen wurde
und gesagt wurde, ja das also diese Aussage können wir jetzt leider nicht treffen,
müssen nachhaltigen Schaden von der Bundesrepublik abwenden.
Die sich diesen NSA Untersuchungsausschuss da anzutun, da habe ich wirklich auch zunehmenden Respekt vor allen die,
Auch vor den Journalisten und den dem Team von Netzpolitik Ork, die das, die sich das da jeweils noch immer antun,
In der nichtöffentlichen Vernehmung war dann Gerhard Schindler dran, BND-Präsident.
Und der musste dann erklären, dass seine Behörde technisch nicht mehr nachvollziehen kann,
welche Abhördaten aus der BND-Fernmeldeaufklärung seit zweitausendvier an die Amerikaner weitergegeben worden sind.
Haben die eine Datenweitergabe an die USA getätigt, die sie nachlässig oder gar nicht kontrolliert,
und auch nicht protokolliert haben. Natürlich haben sie die nicht protokolliert,
du bist ein Geheimdienst und sowas wie das das ähm,
Stasi-Hauptquartier ähm gestürmt wird,
da reinrennen und ähm die Leute am Akten schreddern hindern und ihre Akten daraus schleppen, du nachher eine ähm,
eine Gauck-Behörde hast, wo der, wo der, wo dein Scheißgeheimdienst komplett über Jahrzehnte aufgearbeitet wird. Sowas siehst du halt auch als Geheimdienstdirektor nur einmal passieren.
Da lernt man aus den Fehlern anderer,
So und wenn deine Aufgabe ist, Daten zu sammeln und du der Geheimdienst bist, der der alle Daten, die irgendwo anfallen, sammelt und auswertet,
weißt du, dass du selber keine Daten anfallen lässt, weil wär's ja blöd. Du siehst ja, was damit passiert.
Ja
Ähm woher weiß man eigentlich, was er denn gesagt hat, wenn das äh nicht öffentliche Sitzung war?
Ich vermute, dass diese Informationen sich darauf beziehen, dass das die ähm.
Dass die äh Journalisten mit den Politikern, die in dem nichtöffentlichen Teil sitzen, sich unterhalten. Und dass die Politiker quasi dann Synopsin dessen, was man als ähm.
Essenz, die jetzt keinerlei,
Operationen bedroht, nochmal weitererzählen kann, das tun
Aber wir erinnern uns ja auch daran, dass es schon mehrmals, äh es war dann, glaube ich, im letzten Jahr,
Drohung von ähm ähm Peter Altmaier gab so, ey, wenn ihr da nicht aufhört, dann,
dann machen wir einen Deckel drauf, weil wenn der, wenn der BND Untersuchungsausschuss jetzt plötzlich neue Erkenntnisse,
jede Woche in die Presse bringt, dann werden wir die die Angelegenheit ja niemals los und dann zeigen wir euch alle an wegen Landesverrat. So und ähm.
Hier würde ich sagen, das ist eben so die,
der, der, der zusammengefasste Teil, der dann wahrscheinlich von einem der der Mitglieder oder einem, der mit Security Clearance versehenen Mitarbeiter dann eben der der Presse gesteckt.
Wäre jetzt meine Vermutung.
Wurde er noch zu der Liste mit den zweitausend Einträgen, das war die, die vor ein paar Jahren da schon mal bemerkt wurde. Ähm.
Da sieht man jetzt auch wieder, da kann man jetzt auch wieder erkennen, wie sie wie sie sich ihre Rute legen. Er sagte nämlich ähm.
Auf der Liste mit den zweitausend Einträgen, den Selektoren, die dann da irgendwann mal aufgefallen sind. Sagt Gerhard Schittner,
standen keine Unternehmen.
Merke keine Unternehmen, kommen wir nachher nochmal zu, sondern ausschließlich,
und jetzt sagt er aber.
Also damit bestätigt er ja erstmal den Verdacht, dass der BND.
Den, den, den, den, der, der NSA geholfen hat, europäische Institutionen und äh deutsche Politiker zu äh bespitzeln.
Er sagt aber dann, ja, wir sind ja der BND, wir sind ja auch Auslandsgeheimdienst, wissen Sie ja. Und,
Bereiche, wo wir mit unserer Satellitenschüssel äh dranhalten und so.
Diese ganzen europäischen äh Politikernamen und deutschen Politikernamen,
Die standen dann halt deswegen auf der Selektorenliste.
Weil wir gucken wollten, ob im Nahen Osten und Afrika Anschläge auf diese Personen geplant werden.
Das ist jetzt, so und jetzt kannst du dann halt sehen.
Das ist die Route, die sie jetzt gehen, ne? Einmal werden sie.
Ist der Hierarchieebene äh ein Bauernopfer bringen,
auf der höheren Hierarchieebene, Hierarchieebene hat schon einer gesagt, ja nee, ich habe ähm.
Ich habe das alles so bekommen. Bei mir bestand kein Anlass zur Prüfung, ja? Und,
und außerdem war das ja gar nicht in Deutschland, sondern eben in anderen Ländern. Und.
Ja und vor allem sagen sie ja im Prinzip so äh ja klar haben wir sie überwacht. Aber das ist ja alles nur zu ihrem persönlichen Schutz. Ja, also es könnte ja sein, dass sie jemand überfallen oder entführen möchte.
Stell dir mal vor im Nahen Osten würden welche sitzen und würden Terroranschläge auf zweitausend individuelle EU Politiker vornehmen, was dann los wär?
Ganz ganz interessant, weil ähm,
Das jetzt auch mal schon so so frühzeitig,
erkennen zu können, dass dass sie das ist halt so in der Form noch nicht wirklich verlautbart worden, aber du siehst halt, dass das der Weg ist, den sie jetzt gehen werden. Also
in dieser Zusammenfassung noch nicht, ne? Und da siehst du halt auch, finde ich, auch sehr schön, dass das sehr abgestimmt ist. So, die passen halt alle wie Arsch auf einmal, diese drei Aussagen. Zueinander, ja.
Ja und vor allem versuchen sie ähm so ein bisschen diese,
der Wirtschaft, die es ja nun offensichtlich auch gegeben äh hat oder,
Scheint,
so ein bisschen aus der Thematik, aus dem, aus der Beleuchtung herauszunehmen.
Ging aber nur so halbwegs gut, da kommen wir auch gleich nochmal zu, aber.
Ja, was ich insofern auch bemerkenswert finde, als dass es ja eigentlich auch überhaupt gar kein Geheimnis ist und auch ein Selbstverständnis der NSA, dass natürlich ihre Arbeit nicht nur irgendwie dem politischen Prozess, sondern letztlich auch ihrer lokalen Wirtschaft helfen soll
Also Wirtschaftsspionage ist ein Ziel,
von Geheimdiensten, insbesondere der NSA und alles andere würde uns überraschen.
Alles andere ist absoluter Unsinn.
Auf die eine wirklich schöne Monetarisierungsmöglichkeit dieser gesamten Investition. Da wär's ja verrückt.
Also wärst du einfach blöd.
Ja
Ist die NSA aber nicht einmal Kapitelmarke? Denn,
Die NSA hat nach Information der Bild am Sonntag druckfrisch heute.
Versucht mit Hilfe des BND den deutschen Technologiekonzern Siemens auszuspähen. Siemens ist vielleicht einigen bekannt. Ähm,
machen eigentlich so gut wie alles, ist einer der größten deutschen äh Technologiekonzerne. Ähm.
Angeblich habe also Siemens, sei in den Verdacht geraten, eine möglicherweise eine,
partnerschaft mit dem damaligen russischen Geheimdienst SSN einzugehen.
Und dann haben die Amerikaner sich noch nicht mal entblödet,
äh diese Daten quasi,
Siemens relevante Wirtschaftsspionagedaten einfach durch Bad Aibling zu und da könnte man jetzt sagen, dass das blöd ist, man könnte aber auch einfach sagen, warum denn nicht? Warum,
nicht. So, was haben sie denn zu befürchten? Offenbar ja gar nichts. Ein Sementsprecher kommentierte das mit
Siemens sind keinerlei Fakten im Verantwortungsbereich des Unternehmens bekannt,
würden.
Also das ist jetzt, wie gesagt, neue Meldung von heute Morgen. Ähm,
das heißt, dieser dieser Behauptung oder diesen diesen,
drei offenbar koordinierte,
Zeugen im NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss der Angelegenheit geben wollten, der wurde jetzt auch sehr schön sofort von von äh von der journalistischen äh Seite ähm,
widerlegt. Das finde ich das äh finde ich sehr schön. Gleichzeitig gibt's aber jetzt die Meldung, also es gibt im Moment.
SN ist sicherlich jetzt auch nicht jedem ein äh Begriff, das steht jetzt für äh special communication Service of Rusha und das ist halt ein äh russischer Geheimdienst, der
Überraschung auf das Abhören-Film meldetechnischer Anlagen spezialisiert ist.
Siemens natürlich auch baut.
Beziehungsweise interessant, da kommt man ja, könnte man ja nochmal kurz hier an Siemens,
erinnern. Die bauen ja fernmeldetechnische Anlagen, aber die haben ja ihre Sparte zur Überwachung
schon vor einigen Jahren ähm ausgegliedert und als äh und umbenannt
Trophychor heißt die, haben sie ein eigenständiges Unternehmen draus gemacht.
Naja.
Einerseits scheint es jetzt oder wird jetzt gerade behauptet, es gäbe eine Debatte, ähm,
die Selektoren zu veröffentlichen, die die strittigen Selektoren. Ähm.
Ich hatte in der letzten Sendung schon gesagt, dass ich das für ausgesprochen ähm unwahrscheinlich halte, dass das jemals geschehen wird. Ähm die NSA hat das jetzt auch abgelehnt mit der Begründung, na, welche Begründung nimmt man da wohl.
Na ja, die Sicherheit.
Genau, laufende Operationen könnten gefährdet werden, wenn man jetzt diese Selektorenliste veröffentlicht.
Und in jetzt kommt der Hammer, die NSA droht, damit den Informationsaustausch zwischen den beiden Geheimdiensten für den Fall der Veröffentlichung der Selektoren,
auf Terrorwarnungen zu reduzieren. Das heißt, ey, wenn ihr,
zeigt, dass ihr mit den Selektorenlisten, die wir euch schicken, nicht verantwortungsvoll umgeht.
Arbeiten wir nicht mehr nicht mehr mit euch zusammen, dann bekommt ihr von uns,
keine hochauflösenden Krisenbilder von Krisenregionen mehr.
Bei Entführung deutscher Staatsbürger können wir dann,
auch nicht mehr helfen mit unserer Aufklärung, weil ihr ja zeigt, dass ihr nicht verantwortungsbewusst mit dem mit der, mit dieser Zusammenarbeit umgeht.
Das heißt, die NSA droht uns quasi, droht oder droht dem BND quasi damit, ey, wir ähm.
Probleme bekommen, so, dann lassen wir euch nicht mehr partizipieren. Und das ist ja der, das ist ja der,
ist ja wieder genau dieser Kernpunkt, diese Geheimdienste kooperieren, deswegen muss man auch immer wieder von diesem von diesem,
zwischen zwei Nationen äh auch immer wieder weg äh über den wir da sprechen, ne.
Ähm der zweite, zweite Konfliktpunkt ist, dass die ähm die,
Bundesregierung oder der BND gerne hätte, eine Begründung für die Selektoren, also dass sie sagen, wenn ihr uns schon sowas schickt, ja, dann sagt uns wenigstens mal wieso.
Ihr habt euch ja nicht an die Regeln gehalten, also lasst uns da doch jetzt nochmal irgendwie so ein Layer mit einschnüren, äh dass ihr warum ihr was erfassen wollt,
Dann sagt die NSA natürlich, ja. Das ist äh so schnell erstmal nicht möglich.
Und wir werden euch im Zweifelsfall niemals eine Begründung geben. Denn die NSA das wird da in dem Artikel sehr, sehr richtig gesagt. Die NSA lässt sich doch nicht vom BND erpressen.
Wer seid ihr denn? Was wollt ihr eigentlich? Ja. Habt ihr sie noch alle?
Wer seid ihr denn? So, wollte ihr, wir sollen, wir sollen euch gegenüber,
irgendetwas begründen, das gibt unsere Rechtslage doch überhaupt nicht her.
Ja, hallo, McFly, jemand zu Hause?
So. Dann erklärt, dann erklärt ihr aber mal euren Bundesbürgern, ähm dass ihr, dass ihr die wichtigen Terrorinformationen von uns nicht mehr bekommt.
Hm. Ich frage mich ja wie wie wertvoll der der Datengewinn über die NSA, für BND und damit für die Bundesrepublik Deutschland tatsächlich ist.
Ich glaube, das weiß man gar nicht. Ähm.
Also wenn letztendlich hast du dann einen Riesenhaufen an Daten.
Und für den gibt's ja jetzt nicht unbedingt eine ähm.
Den gibt's ja jetzt nicht unbedingt eine äh,
automatische Erkennung,
Terroranschlag, sondern du hast halt, du du musst, du versuchst immer wieder, andere Houristiken, sucht Techniken oder sonst was darauf anzuwenden und wenn du nichts findest, dann weißt du immer nicht, ob's daran liegt, dass du falsch suchst.
Oder ob es daran liegt, dass du äh dass es tatsächlich keine Aktivität gibt. Ja und,
Insofern kannst du den den Wert dieser Daten nicht abschätzen. Vielleicht hättest du ähm ich meine, man könnte argumentieren,
hätte man den den ähm den Germanwings-Piloten ausreichend überwacht und wäre,
Interesse an Flugzeugcockpitüren ähm.
Und das Sammeln von Medizin, Daten
im Bereich der der Geheimdienste gewesen, dann hätte man vielleicht diesen Massenmord verhindern können. Ja, das kannst du immer behaupten,
aber letztendlich hättest du, kannst du am Einzelfall immer behaupten, wenn du das vorher gewusst hättest, den,
den den Angriff verhindert haben zu können.
Das kannst du über alles sagen. Ich meine, die hätten diese Sendung verhindern können, wenn sie es wenn sie,
weißt du, also wenn sie's geahnt hätten. So, das das kannst du halt immer behaupten oder wenn sie das Budget gehabt hätten. Das kannst du halt posthock für alles immer behaupten. Aber du kannst natürlich nie vorher sagen.
Was du halt wirklich geschissen bekommst. Und ich glaube, dass sie den den Wert dieser Daten natürlich
Es gibt aber natürlich einen Bereich, wo du das sehr, sehr genau messen,
ob sich das lohnt. Und das dürfen wir nicht vergessen
In der Terrorabwehr kannst du immer sagen, ja, haben wir noch nicht genug Geld drauf geworfen oder was auch immer,
aber in der Wirtschaftsspionage kannst du sehr, sehr schnell sofort
auf dem Markt positionieren konntest wie du vielleicht ein eher spioniertes Produkt verbessern konntest und dadurch am Ende dich auf dem Markt besser positioniert hast. Da kannst du sehr, sehr gut ähm.
Messen, ob sich das lohnt oder nicht.
Ich.
In der Terrorabwehr nicht.
Ja. Ich freue mich in dem Zusammenhang auch.
Selektoren nur in eine Richtung? Oder gibt es auch Selektoren, die der NSA zur Verfügung stellt?
Also dann niemals davon die Rede war, kannst du dir das ungefähr vorstellen.
Ja irgendwie auch ganz interessant oder? Also ich meine, weil,
äh das heißt, während die USA.
Also während die NSA, dem BND ganz genau sagt, was sie haben wollen, aber nicht warum.
Der BND äh der NSA noch nicht mal sagen, was sie wollen.
Sondern die NSA sagt immer nur den BND, was, wenn sie der Meinung sind, das ist eine Information ist, die sie teilen können, ohne da selber einen Schaden von zu haben.
In beide Richtungen so laufen.
Schon mal ähm interessanter Gedanke, oder? Also ich meine, die Frage mich halt grade, ob,
sozusagen auch in die andere Richtung eine entsprechende Kooperation gibt.
Also angesprochen wurden ja jetzt zum Beispiel eben sowas, was man was man vielleicht unter,
eher unter Amtshilfe fassen kann, ne? Also hochauflösende Satellitenbilder auf Anfrage, wenn irgendeiner entführt wurde oder ihr eure Soldaten.
Ja gut, aber äh diese Selektoren sind ja nun wirklich spezifisch ein Parameter der Massenüberwachung.
Und äh genauso könnte ich mir ja vorstellen, dass der BND,
Bedürfnisse entfaltet bestimmte Telefonnummern oder IP-Adressen oder sonstige User-Accounts auch im Ausland
von der von
von der NSA quasi für den BND mit überwachen zu lassen in Ländern, wo der BND halt nicht so den Zugriff hat oder zumindest in Kommunikationsnetzen, wo der BND nicht so den Zugriff hat. Was sicherlich eine ganze Menge Netze gibt, die diese Anforderungen erfüllen.
Also von meiner, von meiner ähm mein Godfeeling sagt mir, dass sie, dass der BND wahrscheinlich alles von der NSA bekommen kann, wenn er eine Einzel, eine Einzelfallantrag stellt, so, ja, ähm
der dann halt ordentlich geprüft wird und wo die NSA natürlich sehr genau darauf achten wird.
Mit doppeltem Durchschlag.
Mit doppelten Durchschlag und unterschrieben und so weiter. Das ist halt die, das, so scheint hier schon diese Zusammenarbeit zu sein, ne, dass der die NSA sagt, passt mal auf, Freunde. Hier
Push, so wollen wir die Daten bekommen. Wir haben euch da mal eine wir haben hier mein schönes,
Glasfaser rüber gelegt, da schiebt ihr das bitte durch. Und wenn ihr mal was braucht, dann könnt ihr auch mal freundlich,
so. Vorne da ist die Tür, da könnt ihr euch am Anfang anmelden und dann fragt ihr nach einem Termin, dann können wir euch auch mal was davon ab,
So ungefähr scheint schon, dass das Kraftverhältnis zu sein. Ist aber auch nicht wirklich verwunderlich. So sind halt auch,
und,
Anbietern, ja, also das ist, so läuft es halt, derjenige, der am längeren Hebel sitzt, diktiert die Bedingungen,
in den Gesellschaften, in denen wir als in denen wir heute leben.
Ist ist es völlig unsinnig, auf seine Interessen zu verzichten, wenn man die Macht hat, sie durchzusetzen.
Ja, aber jetzt äh kommt auch die Superempörte Merkel-Regierung und sagt,
du böses äh NSE Land äh äh mit euch, äh euch gehen wir gar nichts mehr.
Und dann letztendlich ich mein am Ende geht's ja dann hier um ja wie gesagt sie drohen ja sofort damit, ja dann kriegt ihr aber keine Informationen mehr
bei Terror und bei Entführung oder so, ne? Oder Terrorwarnung kriegt ihr schon noch, aber wenn da jetzt jemand entführt wird, dann haben wir halt leider keine Zeit mehr, da äh Fotos von zu machen. Und jetzt kannst du dir natürlich vorstellen, dass diese
Ich meine, der auch vor einigen Folgen hier schon mal die Rolle des Innenministers oder der Innen innere Sicherheitsverantwortlichen gewürdigt, so willst du am Ende,
ich meine, die würden sich diese die würden,
ihr Leben nicht diesem Themenbereich widmen, wenn sie nicht ernsthaft darauf hinarbeiten wollen, würden,
jeden Preis die Sicherheit irgendwie zu erhöhen. Und wenn du denen sagst, ja hier, dann wird halt demnächst jemand entführt und du wirst erklären müssen, warum,
du da nicht das nicht aufklären kannst, dann kriegen die natürlich Schiss. Ich würde natürlich sagen.
Liebe Amis, dann müsst ihr mal erklären,
Da müsst ihr mal erklären, wie ihr nicht zur Rettung unserer Bürger äh auf fremden Boden äh äh oder sowas,
tragen wollt, obwohl ihr es könntet, das müsst ihr erstmal öffentlich erklären, da kriegt ihr doch eine Welle rein, äh die sich gewaschen hat,
wenn ihr eure, eure ganze Scheiß Überwachungstechnologie noch nicht einmal in den wenigen Fällen.
Ja und diese Mann, das ist irgendwie so der Grund, warum ich's nicht so recht glauben möchte, dass es wirklich überhaupt,
kein halbwegs automatisierten Rückfluss von Erkenntnissen äh geben kann
lass schreib mir das automatisiert, also dass das sozusagen nicht immer alles nur auf Anfrage ist, sondern dass es schon,
ja, keine Ahnung, so eine Art Selektor auf bestimmten Themenbereichen
nicht unbedingt jetzt Selektor in Bezug auf Massenüberwachung. Wobei ich das auch nicht für ausgeschlossen halte. Also ich meine, was macht denn bitte, wenn
ähm der Bienen, die jetzt, sagen wir mal so,
keine Ahnung, dreißig Leute, von denen sie wissen, dass sie von Deutschland in die USA gereist sind,
die aber jetzt hier Dreck am Stecken haben,
ja? Also die jetzt nicht.
Reisen doch niemals dahin, da kommst du doch niemals durch dieses durch dieses Esther-Verfahren durch, wenn du irgendwo Dreck am Stecken hast. Dafür ist das auch da.
A ähm Esther ist das das schnell äh schnell ein, also über Äste musst du quasi deine Anreise ankündigen. Wenn du.
Nee, aber nicht nicht, dass sie jetzt in dem Sinne eine Bedrohung für die USA sind, sondern die sind halt irgendwie,
Beobachtung, ja und machen jetzt Urlaub in den USA.
Aber auch wieder, wollen aber weiter der BMW BND will aber hat halt eine Überwachungsmaßnahme laufen
Du hast jetzt hier irgendwie so eine kleine dreißig Leute, sagen wir mal drei
ne? Drei Leute, die irgendwie aufgefallen sind so und die sind jetzt äh organisierte Kriminalität
Wir fahren mal hier durch den und mitm Hammer fahren wir da irgendwie durch Texas,
und dann sind wir drei Wochen irgendwie unterwegs und jetzt will der BND diese
Leute beobachten. Schreiben die da einen extra mal ein Fax,
oder fügen sie nicht einfach auch noch diese Telefonnummern,
einer Liste hinzu, die bei diesem Datenabgleich eben vielleicht auch in die andere Richtung geht
just sane, ich meine, vielleicht ist es unwahrscheinlich, weiß ich nicht, aber irgendwo.
Also sicherlich wird der BND ja sowieso alle Leute, die ihr irgendwie unter Terrorverdacht hält, die ganze Zeit mit der B mit der NSA teilen. Und das ist ja auch das ist ja die Grund,
Idee des der Zusammenarbeit zwischen Geheimdiensten, dass sie eben
äh Stretch Intelligence irgendwie tauschen. Insofern glaube ich.
Ja, in dem Fall würde das schon relativ schnell gehen, aber ich glaube, ehrlich gesagt, schon, dass diese Person auch der NSA bekannt wären,
zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo der BND Sie hier ernsthaft wegen Terrorverdacht unter Kontrolle äh unter unter Beobachtung hat, dann müsste der BND gar nicht mehr irgendwie nochmal Bescheid sagen.
Na gut, ist ja nicht unbedingt immer Terrorverdacht, ja, also ich meine, nur nur weil die Leute jetzt hier irgendwie in in Hamburg aufm Kiezer irgendwie ein paar Läden abziehen, äh heißt ja noch lange nicht, dass sie dann gleich in Texas anfangen irgendwie wird um sich zu schießen.
Vorsicht ist die Mutter der Porzellankiste. Wir haben bis jetzt wenig äh wenig Zurückhaltung bei äh bei den Geheimdiensten.
Ja, stimmt auch wieder.
Aber äh ich habe eigentlich, wir wir haben noch gar nicht über den den wirklichen Punkt gesprochen, denn.
Seit Anfang der Woche stellt Bad Aibling dem US-Geheimdienst keine Informationen zur Internetüberwachung mehr zur Verfügung,
gibt's einen auf den Deckel und ähm,
Bevor wir euch das begründen, was wir machen, verzichten wir lieber auf die Da.
Und jetzt ähm.
Könnt ihr ja sehen, was ihr davon habt.
Jetzt berichtet man der BND. Ähm leiste leise beim BND leiste man gerade Überstunden um die Liste
deutscher und europäischer Interessen zu füllen, damit der BND dann halt automatisch irgendwie die Selektoren filtern kann, die die NSA ihm schickt,
Und da gibt's halt jetzt irgendwie Gerüchte davon, dass die, was weiß ich, die gelben Seiten jetzt irgendwie abschreiben oder so. Äh oh um halt da eine Liste zu haben.
Ähm äh um um um eben die,
so dass dass sie halt selber darauf achten, dass sie die europäischen Interessen filtern,
So, aber das es klingt ja jetzt erstmal nach einer Zuspitzung des Konflikts, wenn da auf einmal keine Daten mehr fließen. Aber wie gesagt, der BND arbeitet schon daran, eben eine Liste zu bekommen äh zu zusammenzustellen, damit sie in irgendwann reumütig wieder zu den Amerikanern gehen können,
prognostiziere, ich prophezeie, dass in in ein oder zwei Wochen der BND bekannt geben wird, dass man jetzt eine Liste hat
und die die Selektoren der NSA jetzt automatisch filtert und prüft und so weiter und dass man die Zusammenarbeit wieder aufgenommen hat. Davon dessen bin ich mir relativ sicher.
Also sie haben sozusagen jetzt alle, alle Mobilfunk, Telefonnummern, aller europäischen Parlamentarier mal zusammengesammelt.
Und vor allem halt auch äh Unternehmen. Ähm
aber ich, wie gesagt, meine Prophezeiung ist, äh, ist, dass das, dass sie, dass sie das eben als Feigenblatt nehmen werden, dass sie die Zusammenarbeit wieder aufnehmen, denn Merkel hat bekräftigt,
dass der BND an der Zusammenarbeit mit dem US-Geheimdienst NSA festhalten wird, die Bundesregierung wird nämlich alles daran setzen, die Arbeitsfähigkeit der Nachrichtendienste auch zu gewährleisten, diese Arbeitsfähigkeit kann angesichts der internationalen terroristischen Bedrohungen,
Und jetzt kommt aber, jetzt gibt's aber noch so ein anderes Ding. Da fand ich sehr, ganz, eine sehr interessante Zahl. Ähm.
Andere Partnerdienste des BND haben sich besorgt gezeigt,
geheime Information über Projekte zwischen dem BND und dem.
Eine äh US-Geheimnis NSA an die Öffentlichkeit geraten sind,
und zwar aus zwei Gründen. Einerseits, dass sie sagen, hm, was ist denn irgendwie mit den Sachen, die wir mit euch austauschen, landet das auch alles bei bei der NSA? Und zweitens, das ist, glaube ich, das, was die Geheimdienste insgesamt sehr viel mehr beunruhigt.
Seid ihr noch vertrauenswürdige Partner, die die Schnauze halten oder müssen wir aufpassen, dass wenn wir mit euch irgendwas machen, äh wir morgen irgendwie in eurem blöden Untersuchungsausschuss da äh erwähnt werden.
Mit wie vielen Geheimdiensten der Welt der BND-Partnerschaften hat.
Hm. Das habe ich aber schon gespickt, ne.
Hast du schon gesehen, okay, aber was hättest du denn gedacht, bevor du's gesehen hast.
Das kann ich dir gar nicht so richtig äh beantworten, aber ich fand die Zahl trotzdem doch ziemlich hoch.
Und zwar arbeitet der BND diesem Bericht zufolge momentan mit vierhunderteinundfünfzig Geheimdiensten aus einhundertsiebenundsechzig Ländern zusammen.
Echt äh eine ganze Menge, weil wie viele Staaten gibt's denn derzeit auf diesem Planeten überhaupt?
Ich glaube, das ist was mit hundertneunzig.
Ja. Also.
Aber ich würde echt mal so sagen, so hoch die internationale Spionage-Aktivität. Das ist doch echt,
so einen großen Verbund, ja?
Ja, es ist bemerkenswert, also ich meine äh äh vor allem wüsste ich ganz gerne mal, wie viel wie viele von diesen vierhunderteinundfünfzig alle aus den USA kommen. Ich meine, die USA, die,
irgendwie gefühlt irgendwie zwanzig oder dreißig verschiedene Geheimdienste, stimmt das? Habe ich das richtig in Erinnerung?
Das weiß ich nicht ausm Kopf.
Aber es ist, also es ist wirklich eine enorm hohe Zahl, ja. Also mal gemeinhin äh würde man ja erwarten, man hat da so ein Land und das Land hat einen Geheimdienst. So, ja und in Deutschland, okay, da müssen wir, da haben wir den Verfassungsschutz und da haben wir irgendwie den,
BND und dann haben wir noch den MHD und das war's glaube ich,
sein. Äh habe ich einen vergessen? Also wir haben drei.
Genau, wir haben, wir haben also drei, ne? Die Zahl korreliert ja jetzt auch ein bisschen, wenn du so hundertsechs, so vierhunderteinundfünfzig, hundertsiebenundsechzig, so ungefähr so drei zu eins.
Das ist wahrscheinlich so das das typische Ratio, was mit dem zu tun hast,
schon äh ziemlich bemerkenswert. Ja und das heißt mit anderen Worten, alle Geheimdienste stecken unter einer Decke.
Ja, aber das könnte echt das.
Zusammenschluss sein, ja? Das das ist quasi die intergalaktische,
Vereinigung aller aller Nationen, ja?
Ja da ist die UN ein Scheiß dagegen.
Dass die UN irgendwie einen Kaffeekranz dagegen.
Ja, allerdings.
Wenn wir das gewusst hätten, ja.
Hundertdreiundneunzig Staaten haben wir.
Hundertdreiundneunzig, ne?
Hundertsiebenundsechzig davon äh mitm BND,
Ja, na ja gut, wissen wir Bescheid, ne.
Und Uhl? Uhl warnt natürlich, ja,
Geheimdienste werden sehr empfindlich darauf reagieren, dass in Deutschland als geheimgestufte Information,
in die Öffentlichkeit gelangen. Das ist natürlich auch unsere größte Sorge
Das ist natürlich jetzt auch ich persönlich als Bürger dieses Landes, meine größte Sorge ist, das geheim eingestufte Informationen an die Öffentlichkeit gelang
der BND gesammelt hat in einer Zusammenarbeit mit vierhunderteinundfünfzig Geheimdiensten der Welt.
Ja
Das wäre wirklich, da wäre meine größte Sorge, dass ich darüber was erfahren könnte.
Oh Mann ey. Äh denkt, das kann man sich echt nicht ausdenken.
Ja, so sieht's aus.
Aber ich finde, ich finde das gerade sehr schön, weil wir wir scheinen jetzt grade auf dieser Welle zu reiten. Ne, das Ganze ist jetzt bald ähm.
Wie war das denn? Haben wir schon nee, das zweite Snowden Jubiläum feiern wir dieses Jahr im September, ne?
Äh
Also Snowden war zweitausenddreizehn, ich weiß noch nicht mehr genau in welchem Monat.
Du meinst jetzt die ersten Dokumente rauskamen?
Ja, wann, also wann quasi diese ganze Hongkong-Geschichte und so, also als das losging. Ich habe sogar gestern nochmal die Folge gehört, Logbuch Netzpolitik, weil ich ähm.
Juni, Juni, Juni, zwanzig dreizehn war das.
Okay, das heißt, wir wir feiern bald äh äh das zweite Jahr im,
anno anno S Anno Snowden.
Zwei nach Snowden, wie man so schön sagt. Genau.
AS
Nee, wie heißt das denn dann? Anno Snowdeny, ne? Ey, ist auch egal, Quatsch. Also äh es scheint wirklich so diese diese ähm diese zwei Jahres ähm.
Ja, wie nennt man das so? Dieser dieser Leck jetzt kommen echt grade viel zusammen, ne, also quasi die Lügen von vor zwei Jahren. Die kommen jetzt ans Licht,
Ein sehr schönes Gerichtsurteil, dass die ACU,
erstritten hat. Die ACLU wurde bei uns bisher glaub ich.
Wenig erwähnt.
Aber fälschlicherweise wenig erwähnt. Ähm.
Ist die American Libertys Union. Amerikanische Bürgerrechtsunion.
Und zwar die sind richtig groß. Die haben,
Also die haben richtig viele Mitarbeiter, natürlich hauptsächlich Anwälte, aber auch ähm.
Also auch Aktivisten, die die engagieren sich in allen Bereichen für die äh für die für die Bürgerrechte der der Amerikaner. Ähm.
So ein bisschen wie humanistische Union, kann man sagen.
Ja, nur halt mitm mitm mit einer Hochhausetage in der ersten äh an einer ersten Adresse in New York so, ne? Und also die haben halt richtig ähm die haben halt richtig Power.
Fünfhunderttausend Mitglieder haben sie. Da kann die humanistische Union nicht äh mithalten.
Nee, da kann die humanistische Union nicht mithalten. Ähm,
neunzehnhundertzwanzig gegründet als Reaktion auf die Folgen des äh der Redscare, also der Kommunisten hat's ähm dem McCarthy McCarthy Isum, der da ja so stattgefunden hat, ähm.
Und hatte sich dann eben ähm,
die kämpfen an allen möglichen Frauen. Die haben sich damals gegen die Verbannung der Evolutionstheorie im amerikanischen Schulunterricht eingesetzt,
außer,
wie heißt, Entschuldigung. Martin Luther King Geschichten und so, da waren die überall drin, ähm Watergate, also das ist ein Laden mit einer richtig langen ähm mit einer richtig langen Tradition.
Ähm ist eine Stiftung Stiftung, ähm die substantielle jährliche äh Spenden von anderen diversen Stiftungen, Großspendungen, Spendern und so weiter bekommt und ähm,
ja äh relativ groß, relativ groß abgeht. Ja, die haben einen einen tadellosen Namen in den in den USA seit jetzt inzwischen äh,
fünfundneunzig Jahren ihres Bestehens. Und.
Engagieren sich natürlich auch sehr in diesem ganzen.
Bekannt ist und in Erscheinung tritt, ist der Christopher, der,
ich glaube,
oder sowas ist seine Rolle da, der so nicht ein ein Journalist ist, äh nicht ein ein Jurist ist, sondern ein ähm,
Informatiker oder Soziologe ähm der sich eben so in diesem ganzen Internetbereich so auskennt. Und die haben halt eine
eine Horde an äh an Anwälten, die sich mit allen möglichen Kram auseinandersetzen. Ist wirklich irre. Ich habe die auch mal äh ich habe,
hatte mal Gelegenheit, die zu besuchen. Ähm eines ihrer Büros zu besuchen, das ist echt schon schon wirklich,
irre wie wie die Professionalisiert sind, aber eben, wie gesagt, nicht nur im Internetbereich, sondern überall, wo es ähm,
Bürgerrechte der USA zu vertreten gilt ist die dabei und.
Wir erinnern uns, zweitausenddreizehn eine der ersten Enthüllungen von Snowden war, dass die Telefondienstleister,
die,
Kunden weitergeben. Call Record heißt in dieser an dieser Stelle nicht die Audioaufzeichnung des Gespräches,
sondern wer wen, wann, wie lange angerufen hat.
Meterdaten.
Wir hatten das in der Sendung, da das fand ich auch ganz interessant, nochmal zu hören, diese erste Snowden-Sendung dann noch so sehr ähm.
Ja, so ja, dann haben wir gesagt, das ist übrigens Vorratsdatenspeicherung und so, ne? Haben wir da so drüber gesprochen. Und das ist noch sehr ähm entspannt aufgefasst. Ähm aber die ACU hatte schon wenige Tage danach dann dagegen geklagt.
Weil,
Dass ja die ähm die Metadaten von US-Amerikanern waren. Und sie haben jetzt in diesem Federrekord Recht bekommen,
den Geheimdiensten erlaubt, alle greifbaren Dinge zu schnappen, die für Untersuchungen relevant sind.
Und in der Auslegung haben halt die US-Geheimdienste gesagt, ja okay.
Alle Telefonate aller Bürger sind für unsere Untersuchung relevant. Und in diesem Urteil wurde jetzt halt gesagt so, ja nee, das äh,
So ist das nicht. Es muss schon für eine konkrete Untersuchung sein,
und es reicht nicht, dass es relevant sein könnte, dass du einfach mal alles alle diese Daten sammelst.
Insofern wird dieses Urteil folgen haben, auch für die TA äh Massenlocks, die sie für die Telefonüberwachung nutzen. Da haben wir schon vor einiger Zeit darüber gesprochen, denn,
die sammelt ja ähm ähnliche Daten, teilt die aber zum Beispiel sehr viel mehr mit anderen Behörden als die NSA ihre eigene Daten überhaupt nutzt.
Ähm und dann hat die für die CIA noch eine Überwachung von Finanzdaten ab äh durch, also Kontotransaktionen, auch das wird von diesem Urteil jetzt ins Wackeln gebracht werden.
Kurze Anmerkung, äh,
DE, wer's nicht weiß, äh sieht Truck and Forcement Agency so eine,
Zahlgruppe, die auch so ein bisschen weiß ich, polizeilich, geheimpolizeilich arbeitet, ähm um halt,
zu führen, quasi.
Genau, der die Breaking Bad Fans, wie heißt Frank Hank oder Frank oder Hank heißt, nee, Hank, ne?
Der ist bei der DEA. Ähm genau, auch so eine so eine halbgeheim Polizei auf auf Bundesebene, ja. Ähm.
Weiterhin wird dort äh höchstrichterlich festgehalten, dass Metadaten,
sensibel sind und dass der Begriff, der da verwendet wird, ist,
setz dich am besten mit mit äh verräterisch, also wo quasi das Urteil erkennt an,
dass die Metadaten deiner Kommunikation,
nicht irgendwas sind, sondern dass sie relativ viel über dich aussagen und dass das sensible, persönliche Daten sind. Ja, das muss ja auch irgendwie überhaupt mal in den USA debattiert werden, insofern ist das sehr schön, dass das in diesem Urteil so,
festgehalten wird. Dann äh sagt das Urteil über die.
Maßnahmen, die ergriffen werden, ist eine öffentliche Transparenz,
Diskussion notwendig. Ähm und.
Damit wird also gesagt, die Praxis des äh Fiskord ähm
das äh Foren Intelligence and the Valence Squats einfach äh unter verschlossenen Tür, ähm paar Mal mit einem Hammer auf den Tisch zu hauen, um zu sagen, das ist jetzt alles höchstrichterlich äh genehmigt, das ist eben nicht okay.
Und das ist schon ein sehr schönes, äh ein sehr feines Urteil, was die was die AC Judal erstritten hat und auf Basis dieses Urteils werden sie natürlich jetzt ähm weiterkämpfen und weiterstreiten.
Das Spannende ist, dass diese dass dieses Urteil.
Indem es diese Vorgehensweise als,
illegal dokumentiert? Natürlich auch bestätigt, dass es diese Metadatensammlung gegeben hat.
Und interessanterweise,
gab es die ja offiziell gar nicht, denn James Klapper, wir haben früher ihn vorher schon erwähnt, der Director of National Intelligence,
Intelligence hering, also in einer Anhörung im Senat äh vor dem,
In einer Anhörung vor dem ähm Rede und Antwort gestanden,
und dort wurde er gefragt, ich weiß nicht, ich habe das Video verlinkt, könntest du das jetzt einspielen oder soll ich's einfach auf Deutsch vorlesen?
Ich äh kann das äh kurz einspielen. Wenn wir eine.
Das ist so eine Minute, das ist ganz schön, das mal zu hören. Haben wir mal was was anderes. Ich habe jetzt schon wieder so lange geredet, dass.
Schon wieder. Ähm da haben wir ihn doch hier Sekunde. Kommt sofort.
Wir hören der in seiner,
inleitung noch erwähnt, dass er seit seit zwölf Jahren im Sinned Intelligence Comity arbeitet und das ihm der Begriff Dossier noch nie untergekommen ist und dass er deshalb einfach die Frage nochmal anders stellen möchte, ähm nämlich sammelt die NSA
irgendwelche Daten von Millionen an Amerika von von Millionen von Amerikanern.
Und James Klapper antwortet nicht wissentlich ich glaube er sagt T,
es mag Fälle geben, in denen das vielleicht mal versehentlich passiert, aber nicht absichtlich.
Und das ist ja jetzt ähm,
eine eine ganz glatte, ganz klare Lüge, die dieser ähm Direktor, der der nationalen äh Geheimdienste äh oder dieser dieser,
National Intelligence Director. Ich glaube, das kann man nicht vernünftig übersetzen. Dort vor dem Comedy,
äußert. Und da gab es jetzt eine sehr köstliche Äußerung von,
Robert Lit, dessen General Council, also dessen,
Chefanwalts. Ähm.
Es war einfach nur ein Fehler. Wir machen ja alle Fehler. Denn der James Klepper, der hatte das vergessen.
Vergessen, sorry.
Ja auch aus diesem Video wunderbar hervor, dass er ja auf gar keinen Fall äh nachdenken muss, so ah nee, also jetzt.
Kratzt sich so am Kopf so.
Also, weil sie jetzt alle äh also alle,
Ja, so hätte also glatt noch gesagt so, ja, hier alter Mann und so, man hat ja auch nicht mehr so weit bis zur Rente. Oh ja, meint ja einfach gleich so ein äh.
Nee, nee, nee, nicht wissentlich, nicht, nicht wissen.
Also dass ich ob das eigentlich nur so zur Beruhigung mit reingenommen, um zu zeigen, dass auch in den USA,
gelogen wird darüber. Ähm.
Ich hoffe mal, dass dass da noch was passieren wird. Also den, das ist auch so jemand, den man im Auge behalten kann, der es in diesem äh Bereich sehr engagiert und der treibt da ähm auch seit seit äh Beginn der der.
Seit Anno Snow Dero ähm treibt er da eben die entsprechenden Leute äh vor sich her mit der Macht. Oder mit der wenigen mit den wenigen Einflussmöglichkeiten, die ihr dafür als ähm Senator hat.
Ich finde das, also ich meine, äh das einzige, was ich mir da nur so gedacht habe, ist so viel zu eurer Geheimdienst-Transparenz, weißt du?
Also das ist jetzt ein Thema, vielleicht müssen wir jetzt nicht nochmal aufmachen das Fass, aber dass wir uns hier irgendwie hinstellen, dass man dass es ja wirklich Menschen gibt, zu denen ich mir vielleicht auch zähle oder auch nicht. Äh ich bin ja selber noch gar nicht so so so.
So fest in in meiner eigenen Meinung. Aber so Geheimdienstkontrolle oder Geheimdienst Transparenz ist, glaube ich, ein Modell, wo wir jetzt auch,
sagen können, dass ähm hat jetzt den Lachttest in der Empirie nicht,
bestanden. Das haben wir in der
Das haben wir in in der äh das sehen wir in Deutschland mit der äh mit den entsprechenden Kommissionen und den entsprechenden Kontrollgremien,
einfach auch nur verarscht und belogen werden. Das sehen wir mit dem Klepper,
öffentlich wieder besseren Wissens ähm lügen, um irgendwie ein größeres Feuer auszutreten. Also diese geheim diese Geheimdienst-Transparenz oder Kontrolle, ähm das ist, glaube ich, echt was, was wir uns von der Backe schmieren können.
Ja und das ist auch ein wirklich ein bisschen albern, wenn man sich ähm auch so Angela Merkels Äußerungen dazu anhört, so ja, das ist ja alles schon irgendwie total wichtig sei, mit den Geheimdiensten und überhaupt, man müsste sich ja überhaupt gar keine Sorgen machen
äh an der Stelle können wir nochmal hier auf unsere hundert äh verweisen äh äh Gespräch mit Hans-Christian,
Ströbele, ja, der, ja, also zwar nicht viel Details sagen kann, ja, aber ich glaube, wir haben das Thema auch so ein bisschen
ähm um Fahren, wenn ich mich so richtig erinnere,
PKG, dieses parlamentarische Kontrollgremium
Das ist halt eine Auswahl von Parlamentariern, die das ohne dass sie noch zusätzliche Mitarbeiter für diese äh Rolle, die sie dort ausfüllen, beschäftigen können, äh sich
von ab und zu mal vom Geheimdienst berichten lassen darf, woran die denn so arbeiten
und dann dürfen sie dieses Wissen mit ins Bett nehmen, weil sie dürfen da halt keinem von erzählen.
Genau. Und dann hast du dein Geheim, dann hast du da drei Geheimdienste sitzen, von denen allein einer mit vierhunderteinundfünfzig Geheimdiensten der Welt kooperiert. Wie lange soll das Meeting denn gehen?
Genau, wir können ja das nächste beim nächsten Treffen einfach mal alle Selektoren vorlesen.
Einhundertvierundzwanzig Punkt neununddreißig Punkt siebenundsechzig Punkt achtundvierzig einhundert Punkt siebenundzwanzig Punkt neunundfünfzig.
Na, wir lachen da jetzt. Wir lachen da jetzt dadrüber, ne, aber da da siehst du halt, was wir uns da echt, also,
siehst du, was wir uns da für eine Hydra äh inzwischen eingetreten haben, ne?
Das ist nichts Neues, also Geheimdienste haben immer schon so gearbeitet. Das kriegt halt jetzt einfach immer alles nur etwas absurdere Zahlen jetzt, wo wir eben mit diesen ganzen digitalen Kommunikationswegen
verbunden sind. Auch diese Geheimdienst-Kooperation dürfte es früher schon gegeben haben, nur dass eben die Zahl der Dokumente da
entsprechend niedriger ist. Es wird halt einfach ein bisschen mehr Heu äh von links nach rechts geschaufelt.
Ja, auch ein Sendungstil von Lokbuch. Ja.
Wir haben wenigstens noch eine, eine gute Sache. Nee, haben wir auch nicht, ist auch wieder scheiße, aber ähm,
Es gibt wenigstens ein gutes YouTube Video. Hey.
Ich meine, okay. Wir alle werden von den Politikern belogen, wir werden alle überwacht ähm unser unsere Chefdiplomaten ähm sind irgendwie wirklich erbärmlich und ähm.
Von von Flugzeugen haben wir auch keine Ahnung und ein Auswahlabkommen bekommen wir nicht, aber es gibt ein schönes neues Video auf YouTube. Ähm von Alexander Lehmann. Yay.
Der ja Wiederholungstäter ist sozusagen, mehrfach und immer wieder für hervorragend,
relativ komplexe äh Fragestellungen
in kurze Videoclips zu gießen, die so Aha-Effekte auslösen und,
tötet wurde äh soweit ich weiß von Thomas im Rahmen seines Republica Talks da erstmalig äh vorgestellt. Das war sozusagen die.
Release. Und ja, das ist ähm
Ein schönes Video zum Thema Netzneutralität, in dem all die ganzen Aspekte, die wir hier auch schon immer wieder von Sendung zu Sendung äh besungen haben. Äh nochmal sehr schön darstellt und vor allem sich auch
an den Gegenargumenten,
Orientiert. Deswegen ja auch der Name, so Netzneutralität würde ja töten, wir hatten das ja hier so, Krankenwagen und so weiter, könnte nicht mehr irgendwie zum Krankenhaus kommen und was weiß ich, für einen äh Unsitz, Unsinn und die technischen ähm
Realitäten, die dahinter stehen und äh die
Dynamiken, die eben bei Unternehmen so existieren, um eben so eine Netzneutralität nicht zu wollen. Die werden in diesem Video wunderbar aufgegriffen und wie ich finde, hervorragend visualisiert.
Andere Videos, für die er bekannt ist, äh,
du bist Terrorist, äh zweitausendneun, da ging's um die äh Vorratsseitenspeicherung. Ähm,
rette deine Freiheit und er seine Videos sind, erkennt man auch immer daran, dass er ein, ein wirklich großartigen Sprecher hat. Das sind nämlich nicht er selber, sondern Ernst Walter Simon,
der die immer vertont auch in so einer ähm.
Unverkennbaren äh keligen Stimme, was wirklich immer sehr cool ist,
Netz der Zukunft, weil Mario mal Sprecher und jetzt eben mit,
ähm Netznetralität tötet, wo ich jetzt völlig überrascht feststelle, dass es offensichtlich ein anderer Sprecher ist,
mich aber total überrascht, weil ich meine die Stimme wiedererkannt zu haben. Komisch. Na ja, aber äh die habe ich doch gestern.
Egal. Vielleicht äh also okay. Wie dem auch sei, Florian,
Ist auch ein sehr guter Sprecher. Ähm in dem Video Netzneutralität tötet von Alexander Lehmann, der ähm wirklich äh zu jedem einzelnen dieser Themen sehr, sehr sehenswerte Videos gemacht hat. Und in diesem Video eben für.
Äh für die Seite, save the Internet,
wirbt sich dort eben mit Faxnachrichten.
An die Abgeordneten zu wenden oder mit E-Mails oder mit Anrufen,
und ähm ich denke, wir können an dieser Stelle nur,
wiederholen, wie wichtig das ist, diese ganze Netzneutralitätssache steht grade mal wieder ganz besonders ähm,
schlecht gegen uns und ich glaube, wir haben wie schon so viele Male zuvor jetzt nur die nur eine Chance, wenn wir.
Einmal wirklich in Ruhe äh zu sezieren und zu äh
zu klären, ja? Und das ist halt ähm.
Aber äh es ist wichtig, wie dieses Video sehr schön zum Ausdruck bringt.
Und das bringt uns dann auch schon an das Ende der Sendung. Hm.
Ja, geringfügig. Mal gucken, was jetzt noch einfällt.
Es gibt nicht mehr so sehr viel äh zu sagen. Du wolltest, glaube ich, noch einen Dank aussprechen.
Ja, danke an eine anonyme Person und dann nochmal die kurze Erinnerung daran,
sich doch bitte kurz bei mir zu melden, wenn man mal,
Mail Ende zu Ende verschlüsselt äh verschicken möchte, um da irgendwie so,
Armstrong Moment,
Ist das nicht der erste Mann auf dem Mond.
Nein, das ist nicht der erste Mann auf dem Mond, sondern das ist irgendwie der Dauergewinner, der nein.
Wie wie wer war denn der erste Mann auf dem Mond?
Ich weiß nämlich nur noch wegen dir Tim. Wegen dir weiß ich nämlich, den zweiten. Ich habe mir, ich habe mir den zweiten gemerkt, weil ich irgendwann mal in irgendeiner Sendung gesagt habe, keine Sau interessiert sich für den zweiten Mann auf dem Mond. Und dann hast du gesagt
und ähm seitdem habe ich mir nur den gemerkt. Wie war denn der erste Mann auf dem Mond?
Neil Armstrong.
Okay und wer ist der, der die ganze Zeit immer durch öffentliche Veranstaltungen geht und den Leuten auf die Fresse haut, die überhaupt nee, wer nicht aufm Boot gewesen.
Keine Ahnung.
Scheint ein ganz guter Name zu sein. Ich kenne verschiedene Leute, die äh Abendschwung heißen und irgendwie bemerkenswertes geleistet haben.
So, wir verlinken, wir wir verlinken's zur allgemeinen,
unserer Hörer.
Verschiedene Armstrocks. Eine Auswahl von,
Abendschaumstier besonders beeindruckend in Erinnerung geblieben sind. Da kommt dann auch Joe Armstrong noch dazu. Dann äh haben wir sie alle beisammen.
Was hat auf welchem Planeten ist Joe Armstrong gelandet?
Auf dem Erlangen Planeten hat die Sprache Erlangen gefunden.
Ja, okay. Das ist natürlich auch so ein Monlandungsmoment.
Na ja, absolut, also es war nur ein sehr kleiner Schritt für ihn, aber ein großer Schritt für die Telekommunikationsindustrie.
Okay, dann haben wir jetzt die die Armstränge durch und ähm.
Genau. Die Sendung auch.
Die Sendung auch. Vielen Dank. Tschau, tschau.
Bis bald, tschüss.